over those 300 000 games
played over the board online all kinds
of variations what's a game that stands
out to you as particularly one you're
proud of or or maybe what's the Hikaru
mortal game or a strong candidate for
this yes they're they're two games
there's a game that I won against Boris
galfond
um in 2010 where I offered a queen stock
I think on five consecutive moves second
sacrifice sacrifice the queen yeah yes
so coming through with the lingo can you
take me to that game this there's one
sequence in the late middle game where
um
it's funny because I actually I I think
I because I remember I tried to show
this game to Peter actually Peter till
and I confused the move order right in
the late middle game so I don't want to
do that again 2010 yeah 2010 it was yeah
what what kind of opening is this that's
the king's Indian defense
so the knights are all
what's with the bringing the night back
yeah I have the black pieces and you
want to push the pawn the uh the make
room for the pawn yeah normally the
king's any you try to is sort of like
storming with the pawns uh on the king
side where the white king is seriously
now I push and I start pushing all my
pawns forward are you happy with this
position with all the Pawns in diagonal
like this with the knives behind it this
looks this is this is no this is this
nowadays this is very well known as a
standard Theory
um but at the time I I the reason that I
was aware of this is because I played a
tournament I think in Montreal I think
it was Montreal like the year the summer
before and one of my friends had
actually played this variation with the
black pieces so I was aware of it and it
seemed very dangerous but I'm from the
black perspective yeah I feel like it's
very hard for white to play yeah very
hard for white to play it felt feels
like you're getting attacked you're King
you see the black pawns are coming down
towards the king and it's very hard to
defend and also a lot of players don't
like being attacked generally you try to
avoid positions where your king is under
Fire which comes back to what I said
about Magnus as well like he doesn't
like it when his King is under Fire and
so therefore
um You Can't Always Get That BC White
had to play along to get to this point
as well if white didn't want something
this uh this double edge and this
complicated he could have avoided it so
is the is the is the black Bishop also a
threat are you like yeah the light
Square Bishop in the king's Indian is uh
vital to any attacking possibility
you're always likes you don't want to
lose that Bishop if you can help it got
it and so the he's bringing out the
knights
is there a particular moment that's
interesting to you here so also keep
going yeah there's so I play Rook F7
this is all all standard yeah so I take
take now this is actually this is an
exception to the rule normally the
king's Indian you don't want to break
this Pawn chain from the these are the
four Pawns in a row The Connect Four
why'd you break it because it's an
exception where you can do that there
almost are no variations in the king's
inning where you do that you almost
always Retreat the bishop
um to guard the pawn the bishop to fa
you break the pawn chain because it's an
exception to the rule
um because you're not actually worried
about the about white being able to push
the pawn to D6 here it was probably the
best game I ever played so it keeps
going
A5 G4 yep
no no no now the diagonal's there again
that that's that that looks threatening
right like white Beasley is trying to
guard the king he's gonna Retreat this
Bishop from C5 to G1 as you'll see in a
c in a second actually not quite yet
yeah it goes now he goes here and so
he's trying to guard his King with the
bishopon on G1 uh but I'm able to keep
keep attacking here in the next is there
any case to be made for you to take the
pawn here uh no that would actually be a
mistake I mean it's very high level but
it's a mistake because white will
actually not recapture the pawn and and
uh I it yeah this is very high levels oh
oh so the pawn is the pawn like the pawn
will be ends up in front of the king
yeah it stops white from being the white
king from being attacked basically all
interesting so your Pawn is stopping the
their King for being a tactical
so yeah so the pressure continues from
you right and then I sack is that is
that off wait wait what's the sack oh
the Knight takes Pawn Yeah is this uh
what are the strengths and weaknesses of
you
throwing the Knight well basically I'm
gonna get this uh I'm destroying the
protection in front of the white king
the white pawns there and willing to
take risks but please I basically want
to open up the king and try to check me
if I don't check me and I'm probably
gonna lose the game here in the center
of the board so yeah and now there's
some very nice moves after punch Pawn I
take this because now what takes the
queen I push the pawn forward on his
checkmate
uh so give me a second so
your night is take you're losing pieces
ever left and right right and you're
pushing the pawn forward check
he takes the pawn
uh The Rook check
so just check check Non-Stop and I same
themes I keep going for this checkmate
with a pawn or a bishopon on the Square
in front of the king
you see the queen is still hanging in
fact I actually sacked the queen again
he never took the queen he couldn't take
the queen because it'd be Checkmate got
it
so constantly and that's what you mean
by sacrifice he didn't actually yeah
yeah he couldn't take you to have gotten
checkmated but anyway Smoke Clears and
I'm up material here and and I win this
game so this is the game that I would
say is like why why why did it stand out
I mean it's beautiful but just the fact
that
um it's mainly that I was able to offer
the queen sacrifice so many moves in a
row you almost never have that
opportunity
um and actually normally the games
you're going to consider your best
involve sacrifices and if you can
sacrifice the queen that makes it uh
very memorable there's just this
constant theme of uh this this one
Checkmate idea how often do you
play with the sacrifice of a major piece
like how often do you find yourself in
that position pretty rare because
players tend to avoid these sorts of
situations players don't like games that
can go either way so when when like both
players have to sort of cooperate you
have to want that kind of game in order
for that situation to arise and a lot of
games at the top neither player wants to
go into that situation for the most part
so you don't really have those
opportunities
nevertheless stockfish loves those
opportunities the yeah the sacrifices
well that's one thing also that we're
starting to learn more and more is that
stockfish and the other programs they
don't care about pawns you can sacrifice
one pawn two pawns three Pawns in a lot
of cases if the rest of your pieces are
very active and that's something that we
kind of knew on a basic level about the
initiative is what we call it in chess
where like you'll give up material but
your pieces are very well placed but we
didn't realize just how how important
that is and computers will do that all
the time now all the time and even
actually like they're in this variant
Fisher random is another another variant
where you arrange a piece on the back
row they will gladly sack Rooks for
Bishops or for Knights all the time all
the time and so you take from that
material imbalance or the material you
give up doesn't matter as much as having
this this attack or having this piece on
certain squares well as long as you can
hold on to the attack right and
computers can't but yeah it's also very
tricky because when we as humans
sometimes you'll look at our opening
variation and you'll see something like
this and you want to do it in a game but
the problem is we don't know how we're
supposed to follow it up afterwards yeah
and so if you do that and you don't know
how to follow up afterwards very
oftentimes will make mistakes we'll try
to look in a human way and then of
course all you end up losing in the long
term because you've given up too much
material so it's a very double-edged
sword but that's why it's dramatic and
what people love those kinds of
sacrifices because you're putting it all
in the line what's the what's the other
game
oh it was the game also with the Queen's
sacrifice um it was a game against this
uh polish player Michael krasenkow uh it
was played in Barcelona in 2007 I
believe it was I also I sacrificed a
queen for one Pawn to just bring the
king out into the middle of the board
and you actually sacrificed it or yes I
did sacrifice I took a pawn
yeah absolutely
and you're again black yes yeah this
game you can just skip forward to about
like the 20th move roughly what's the uh
what's the opening uh this is I think
it's like a Catalan it says neocataline
so yeah it's basically a Catalan opening
generally very slow you know Catalan
declined yeah
yeah and now here I sack the queen for
the pawn
or no sorry I take the Knight first
sorry Knight C6 keep going so
yeah
by the way the pawn structure here is a
mess or is missing yeah if I take the
knight uh you take the Knight with a
rook yeah uh what's the discovery my
Queen's under attack now
so when he takes the Knight The Rook on
B1 is attacking my queen got it so they
just get got it no yeah you you
yeah you throw your queen into the
middle
um and check check the king
wait a minute that's not right yeah it's
one Pawn it's it's a queen for a pot for
a pawn yeah and the King takes your
queen
what was the thinking here well crazy
magic King is King is uh King has to go
up the board and the king is very
vulnerable in this position see but
you're gonna have to keep checking here
then yes uh Bishop checks King
Rook checks
night checks did you see all of this
ahead yeah I mean I had not all of it
but I I figured there had to be some way
to win here with the King too many
attacking pieces in your end that could
duel well it's just basically the king
the only piece that can sort of guard
the king is the queen on D1 that's the
only piece if I can just keep checking
I'm gonna be able to win win here so it
goes there and now I think I played yeah
I played this move oh no check because
I'm threatening to move the Rook over
one square and make a Checkmate got it
and then there was that the Rook takes
your knight
and then you take it right back with a
check
now I still want to scoot The Rook over
to check check on the H6 Square the dark
Square
I think they resign here are they making
well he resigned yeah he did resign here
yeah because I just moved the Rook over
to that dark Square in front of the pond
and that would be Chuck mate
dark Square in front of the pawn so 86
yeah because now the bishop covers the
light square is there something he can
do to to mess
um not really there I don't think
there's nothing with a queen Chuck mate
nothing with the queen I guess he's
gonna lose the queen yeah I think it's
just actually Force Checkmate here in a
couple of moves I don't think there's
any way to stop it even if he loses his
Queens yeah it's it's a force checkmate
fascinating and so like that you you
can't purely calculate but you can have
some intuition also I think what it is
is in such situations you know that
there is at least a draw I could always
just check him with my Rook if I wanted
to to make a draw so that also gives me
some margin where if I calculate after I
play the move and I calculate it doesn't
work out I can still make the draw
are you uh I mean for fun dude do you do
the sacrifices of this sort when it's
not the serious competitive uh online
events or over the board I do actually
do this quite frequently and I wish
there were more opportunities but top
level chess it's it's become harder and
harder because due to computers
everybody's very very well prepared in
the opening they know the first like 15
to 20 move sequences and no matter what
you do so it's very the the room for
creativity is less and less which makes
it which means you have less less of
those types of games